en France segoline royale est donc la
première femme susceptible de devenir
présidente de la République première
femme candidate de l'histoire du PS elle
est aussi la première à avoir pris en
2004 la tête d'une région un long
parcours politique elle fut plusieurs
fois ministre sans pour autant faire
partie des éléphants du PS javiberg
Patrick
desmi c'est la meilleure de mes enfants
disait le colonel Jacques royal en
parlant de sgolen le militaire de
carrière ici à gauche avait deviné une
force de caractère mais de ce qui
faisait régner la discipline martiale
jusque dans sa famille de H enfants elle
garde un souvenir douloureux de petite
fille toujours fait sentir que nous
étions des êtres inférieurs et c'est
peut-être là aussi que date un peu mon
engagement politique je ne voulais pas
ressembler aux femmes de ma famille des
femmes soumises et au fond je me suis
dit jamais comme ma mère jamais comme ma
mère chez les royales les fill étaent
destiné aux emplois subalternes ou bien
à être épouse au foyer seolen royale
fera tout l'inverse de brillante études
Science Po puis Lena c'est là qu'en 78
elle rencontre François Hollande mais
sans se marier sans se soumettre en
quelque sorte au départ pour moi c une
revendication aussi de liberté quand
même en politique d'emblé les plus
hautes sphère le couple travaille à
l'Élysée avec François mitéran sous la
coupe de jacquatali cgolen royale a tout
juste 29 ans elle est la seule femme
dans cette assemblée de messieurs austèr
qui écoute la bonne parole du conseiller
spécial dans un Milie d'homme élu député
en même temps que son compagnon elle se
souvient encore du slogan de son premier
adversaire un homme de chez
nous pour quelqu'un qui a fait campagne
sur le thème d'un homme de chez nous je
crois que être battu dans son propre
canton c'est quelque chose d'assez grave
pour lui souventolen Royal affirme ses
choix par l'image lorsque ministre elle
accepte les caméras à la maternité c'est
pour dire qu'on peut travailler et
procréer lorsquelle défend le chabichou
du Poitou c'est un costume
traditionnel
c'est lui qui grâce à son odeur a porté
le Poitou à l'honneur nos braves Chab
pendant la guerre ont repouss l'enemi de
la frontière et quand l'image ne lui
plaît pas comme sur cette publicité pour
des string lance une campagne pour la
dignité des femmes çane pas d'être
traité de M la pudeur autorité moraleol
Royal revend mot populiste comme l'ont
qualifi ses adversaires sautodésigne
comme la candidate du peuple ne vous
laissez pas plusoir à la politique oui
par ces hommes et n'hésite pas à
déranger lorsqu'elle annonce son idée
pour les jeunes délinquants il s'agit de
créer des lieux d'encadrement à
dimension militaire carte scolaire 35
heur pour les prof juriscitoyens prend à
chaque fois le PS à rebrousse poil mais
ceux qui la connaissent bien savent que
c'est précisément ce qui marche on est
prisonnier entre les mots
technocratiques et les mots en isme et
elle elle utilise des mots tous les
jours des mots de la belle langue et
ça le
respect l'ordre juste la politique ce
n'est pas un concours de beauté avait
dit Jean-Luc Mélenchon lorsqu'elle
annonça qu'elle songeait à se présenter
il y a un peu plus d'un an Solen Royal
avait encaissé elle contournera le PS en
lançant son site et son association
désire d'avenir mais elle n'oubliera
jamais le matchisme jusqu'aux dernières
heur de la campagne interne dans ce
plaidoyer en meeting à Paris femme violé
femmes infériorisées femmes écrasées
inégalité salariale violence faite aux
femmes mariage forcé inégalité dans la
formation professionnelle ségolen royale
a gagné son Paris pour la première fois
une femme représentera un grand parti à
l'élection
présidentielle